- American electric vehicle
companies were the biggest
things since sliced bread
just a couple years ago.
Names like Lordstown Motors, Fisker,
and Nikola were once hailed
as the next big thing.
The heir apparent to Tesla
and the companies that were
gonna usher in the next wave
of the American car.
Well, that hasn't happened at all.
EV companies that had valuations
that rivaled American auto giants Ford
and GM are now on the verge
of seeing their stock prices go to zero.
I'm going to explain what's happening
to these high flying electric
vehicle companies, why many
of them are on the verge of insolvency
and what this means for the
future of the American car.
Let's get into it.
What's happening to American EV companies?
Tesla has done extraordinarily well.
It's the most valuable
car company in the world,
and its stock is up more
than 100% year to date.
But the other EV companies
have fallen apart
over the past year or so.
One extreme example, hydrogen
electric vehicle startup
Nikola had a valuation of
nearly $29 billion in 2020
that made it one of the most valuable
car companies in the US.
Not anymore, Nikola stock
has fallen by around 95%
and the company is worth
around a billion dollars today.
Its stock has never fully
recovered from a short sellers
report filled with accusations,
including against founder Trevor Milton.
He was convicted of fraud
and recently sentenced
to four years in prison,
but Nikola hasn't even been
the worst performing EV stock.
Companies like Lordstown, Faraday Futures
and Proterra have all
seen their stocks fall
by 99% since going public.
Short sellers who make investments
that company stock prices
will fall, have piled in
and gotten paid.
Faraday, Nikola
and Proterra have been the
best performing short bets in
the automotive sector all year.
My colleague George Downs covers
transportation and he says,
- Making cars is hard.
There is no simpler way I can say that.
- George, what's going on in the EV space?
- So when a lot of these
companies went public in
2020, 2021, many legacy automakers had yet
to release their kind
of flagship EV models.
So production of Ford's F-150
Lightning hadn't started yet.
These startups didn't have any
existing internal combustion
engine production lines that they needed
to maintain or pivot from.
So it seemed that they
could possibly bring an EV
to market quicker and easier than some
of the legacy car companies.
The problem is whether
you're a young startup
or an old automaker,
engineering is engineering,
manufacturing is manufacturing,
and supply chains are supply chains,
there are no real shortcuts.
And even Tesla's CEO Elon Musk
said that the company went
through manufacturing hell in 2017,
supply chains got snarled for
pretty much every automaker
and startups struggled to get
the parts that they needed.
And every day that you're
not getting a vehicle off the
production line and selling
it to customers is a day
that you're potentially losing money.
- But data show Americans
do want electric cars.
EV sales continue to rise in the US
and are seeing exponential growth,
Analytics firm, Cox
Automotive estimates that
around 300,000 electric
vehicles were sold in the third
quarter, making up around
8% of all auto sales.
That's more than double
the number of sales
and shares seen in the
third quarter of 2021
and four times the sales
and shares seen in the
third quarter of 2020.
So what does the future look
like for electric vehicles?
A report from our
colleague, Amrith Ramkumar
and Shane Shifflett recently found that
of 43 public electric vehicle
companies they studied,
18 were on track to run
out of cash by the end
of next year if they didn't
cut costs or raise new capital
and seven of those had
just weeks of cash on hand.
When contacted by the journal,
several companies said they raised
or are planning new financing
and or cutting costs.
So is it game over for EV
companies here in the US?
- I think what you're seeing
now is the hype starting
to fade away, but reality setting in.
So the companies that are in
a stronger position are the
ones that have actually
managed to get their EVs
into the hands of paying customers.
But even the big players are reassessing.
GM abandoned its target to
build 400,000 EVs by 2024,
and Ford has pushed back its targets
as our latest WSJ reporting points out.
There's still a bunch of
companies losing a lot of money,
so it's likely there's
gonna be more bloodshed.